I definitely have a lot of thoughts
about Wonder Woman three I think Steve's
done I think Steve Steve's done his bit
too spoiler as I felt about Wonder Woman
- I never want to commit to something
until you know that you're you know that
you're feeling it right then and there
and so that moment hasn't come yet but
I'm pretty excited about Wonder Woman's
arc and trajectory overall and of course
there can always be a little more Chris
Pine because that's isn't always
necessarily a guarantee and there's one
room in the world yeah we'll see I wish
them all the luck in the world now Diana
Prince's second big-screen adventure
won't hit theaters until later this year
but in the meantime her pals Steve well
Chris Pine heads to the small screen
reteaming with director patty Jenkins on
the new limited series I am the knight
[Applause]
[Music]
and the show's la premiere was a mini
reunion of sorts when Wonder Woman
herself
gal gadot stepped out to support Chris
and Patty I loved the visuals of it the
aesthetic of the colors of the cars the
clothes the whole bit I'm very proud of
my hometown we get to see it and all of
its architectural glory and very proud
of this series that we did it's has a
bit of the crime thriller in it a bit of
the whodunit but also is you know a
dramatic tale about two people trying to
figure out what the hell to do with
their lives and see if they can be
better people than the people that came
before them it's about ten years ago
that I met this woman and she told me
her story and I assumed that I would
hear this sort of interesting story and
what she told me
blew me away all these years later I
kept telling the story and telling the
story and finally the moment came and I
was able to get it made and so it's a
special night this carpet has just been
people gushing about you especially your
director patty Jenkins she's someone who
has such a clear vision of what she
wants she knows how to work tick you
late it well she knows how to hire well
she is the great captain of the of the
team the general of the army
you get the fun out of Chris and this
very like kind of dark tail I think that
Chris makes me laugh naturally I think
we both believe that there's is there's
a little bit of everything in all things
so in anything dark there's still a lot
of light and a lot of sense of humor we
love to laugh and he no one makes me
laugh as hard as Chris does and so we we
certainly enjoyed the moments where it
was appropriate
[Music]